And is a little novel.
The Hamlet,
William Faulkner has a line he puts in the mouth of one of his characters.
It's one of the Snopes is there.
Lots of Snopes is and Faulkner's novels,
especially that novel.
It comes from the deep dark heart as only Faulkner really wrote it of the burden
of the past of memory,
of slavery,
the civil war and reconstruction on the south,
but he's really referring to all of us.
He's referring to humanity.
It's one of the best single sentence,
descriptive explanations of what happened to the legacy and memory of all these
events I've ever read.
He has his character say
only thank God,
men have done learned how to forget quick what?
They ain't brave enough to try to cure.
I'll do it once more.
Only thank God men have done.
Learn how to forget quick what they ain't brave enough to cure.
Can't solve that problem
way down to heavily by that problem.
Don't have the solutions for the all the world's hills.
It's an ancient problem.
It's a natural problem.
Forget it.
Try to forget it.
Structure ways
to forget it.
Americans weren't forgetting by 1876 at least in a host of ways.
They were about to have the magnificent centennial over their independent.
Now that year will bring as we'll see you in a moment,
a pivotal election to say the least.
It will end in a dispute it the first,
not the first really the second great disputed election in American history and
a sorted political compromise that most of us in textbooks and in teaching still
call the end of reconstruction.
But I'm gonna leave that question of when reconstruction ended tall,
the great forthcoming books of my various graduate students who are going to
solve that issue.
And I'm going to probably suggest before we finished that it's never quite
ended.
But listen to us just a couple of the public commentaries that year of America's
live independence and what they were thinking about.
The New York Evening Post announced the great work of the of the century it said
is finished and the year,
which is about to dawn will be the very first one holy free from the duty of
dealing with the old and dangerous subject.
Slavery died in this country 10 years ago,
but not until now have we finished the work of readjusting our national life to
the new order of things.
Not until now have the questions which grew out of slavery.
Ben Fully and finally settled not until now have the echos of the war died out
of our politics and our lives.
Not just listen to how conclusive that is.
It's over folks
or the Springfield Republican,
a Republican Party paper and old abolition is paper 1876 we must get rid of the
southern question.
There is no chance or hope of healthy politics until we do get rid of it.
So long as the war issues are capable of being warmed over from year to year,
an election to election,
so long as the large section of the country is disturbed by violence and
paralyzed by miss government.
So long as white is a raid against black.
So long will our politics be feverish with this disease?
Multiple choice question,
what's the disease?
You can make up the answers and you can pick
or the New York Times,
not a liberal paper.
In these years,
10 years ago,
the north was nearly United in a feeling of sympathy for the Friedman and in the
determination to defend their rights.
Now,
not a few believe that the rights of the whites are those which have been
infringed upon.
Historical memory is always a contest.
It's always a struggle.
It's always a battle.
A debate over who gets to own it,
control it,
narrate it,
organize it,
declare it,
and everybody was trying.
But in Philadelphia,
they put on the biggest show of the United States.
Ever put on the biggest show the United States had ever attempted.
The United States Centennial Exposition in Philadelphia in 1876 throughout that
from spring all the way through the fall was attended by.
It's really almost hard to believe,
but it was attended by 10 million people.
Yeah,
that was close to one fourth of the entire US population.
Imagine today an exposition and event attended physically.
Now not on,
you know,
the Internet and television attended by one quarter of us.
They had a wax replica of Cleopatra,
their huge thing.
What the hell that had to do with the U s centennial?
God only knows,
but,
but you know,
we're don't.
To be a great country,
you've got to reach over history and back to classical times.
The great theme of the exposition of course though,
was machines.
It was the machine age.
It was the excitement of technology.
They had a telephone there,
a type writer
and electric light,
a new floor cloth called linoleum.
They celebrated packaged yeast and something called,
are you ready?
The internal combustion engine,
the Corliss steam engine,
gigantic thing.
It's,
it's now today in the Smithsonian in Washington.
You can see this.
It's an amazing thing.
Uh,
was 700 tons and 40 feet high and people looked at it and all this thing was
going to make energy for the future.
Machines and technology were,
it was said over and over and over and over.
We're remaking American society and would remake its future and would make the
United States the greatest manufacturing,
industrial producing nation on earth.
True.
All of this national self-congratulation ignored or masked some of the less
admirable features of American life.
And of course it would.
You don't have a national centennial celebration and then say,
oh,
by the way,
you can buy your ticket here to celebrate and you can buy your ticket here to
look at all of our tragedies.
I mean,
we don't do that,
do we?
But that doesn't mean that history is not happening.
The Pennsylvania and Massachusetts exhibitions,
every state had one,
made no mention of the great labor strikes that adjust hit their states.
Even though 27 of the very textile mills that had just been struck and fall
river Massachusetts exhibited there,
wares at the exposition.
There's no mention whatsoever of the enduring economic depression,
which is still going on.
In 1876,
there was a woman's pavilion added as an afterthought at the last minute.
It honored at,
at,
uh,
housed collections of needlework and weaving and demonstrations of power
or no mention whatsoever of women's political subordination or activism,
the crusade for women's suffrage,
which was going on everywhere.
Women's suffered,
just tried to,
to,
um,
be recognized and to protest.
In fact,
the exhibition weren't allowed to women's place in this was essentially a
political
for African Americans.
There were no exhibits at all about them.
They were even excluded from the construction crews that built all the halls.
There was something called a southern restaurant,
which according to the guidebook,
featured quote,
a band of old time plantation darkies performing songs.
There was a bail of Benjamin Montgomery's cotton from Davis,
Ben Mississippi,
which won an agricultural metal at the exposition,
beating out cotton from all over the south and from Brazil and from Egypt and
the Fiji islands and other places,
but no mention whatsoever made of the recent violent overthrow of
reconstruction.
And Mississippi.
American Indians were represented at the exposition,
but almost exclusively depicted as a people of the past or as harmless and
primitive noble savages.
They were either a vanishing Indian
or a Indian of a kind of cultural mystique,
a deeply American mystique.
And then came the news right after the 4th of July
or some real Indians rudely interrupted all the celebrations.
The news arrived,
the General George Armstrong Custer had been defeated,
indeed wiped out all his men killed.
Well,
almost all by the Sioux led by sitting bull and crazy horse at a place called
little big horn Custer's last stand images of which would end up behind the bar
in every saloon west of the Mississippi and I a hell of a lot of them east of
the Mississippi for the rest of that century.
That victory for the Indians.
Of course,
it'd be a pyrrhic victory in their struggle to hold onto land culture place.
What was also occurring here by 1876 of course,
the subtext of this great national celebration,
if not its central theme,
was the sectional North South Reunion,
the great reconciliation from the civil war.
Now one might say that's inevitable.
It had to happen.
I said,
this is beginning of our whole unit on reconstruction.
North south had to come back together.
Southwest,
I'm gonna go somewhere good and exile them all that Brazil.
Okay.
But in that reconciliation,
as Faulkner said in that passage,
there is a tremendous amount of forgetting going on about what that which people
cannot or will not cure and what is going on in great part is that piece among
the whites at Frederick Douglass had worried about the year before in 1875 back
up with me now load 1874 at least quickly.
We're going to look at two elections today,
which kind of move us toward what we can at least call some vestige of an n
double reconstruction.
The 1874 congressional elections took on a significance that off your
congressional elections don't always have,
although we've had some of these kinds of off your congressional elections in
our own lifetime.
In recent years,
like 1994 which you may or may not remember when the Gingrich Republican
movement too over the Congress and after 40 years of democratic rule,
they were gone and then in those six the Democrats take back both houses of
Congress,
et Cetera.
In essence,
the 74 congressional elections were a referendum on reconstruction.
You don't remember.
The sauder house case had come out in [inaudible] 73 the depression had set in
surely by 1874 deeply and certainly by the fall elections of 1874
this became the great takeover of Congress by the Democratic Party,
so under duress since the civil war,
since they had been the party in many ways that had not favored the war for the
union or the war to free the slaves
and its coverage in the press after this tells it all the buffalo advertiser
says in the wake of it,
the Republican,
it's headline,
Republican parties struck by lightening,
it said,
or another newspaper,
the Louisville Courier Journal,
Democratic paper said headline,
busted the radical machine gone to smash.
Well,
what happened was this
Democrats captured the House of Representatives.
It went from a Republican majority of 110 that's how many more Republicans
they're worth and Democrats on the eve of this election.
This is the Republican Party now that has run Congress since Abraham Lincoln's
election
for sixth the whole civil war and reconstruction.
It's been a Republican Congress.
Anyone from a Republican majority of 110 overnight to a Democratic Party.
Majority of 60
in the wake of the election,
there were 109 Republicans left and there were 169 democrats
ended up set patterns.
The election did in state after state after state,
there were two,
at least two decades old in American political culture,
Republicans,
Democrats took back at a small majority of the Senate,
but if the state and local level,
it was just as important,
Democrats won the governor's office in New York and Massachusetts.
In fact,
they weren't in the governor's office in something like 23 states.
Okay?
Of 35 states holding elections,
23 state legislatures went to Democrats,
southerners.
Now with their party,
the Democratic Party,
which was now National Party
no longer have to feel like aliens in their native land,
and this is what newspapers all over the place kept writing over and over in
celebration.
Listen to this one.
This was a Tennessee paper and Nashville paper,
which said,
all right,
cool.
The recent election was not an election,
said the Tennessee paper.
It was the country coming to a halt and changing front.
The whole scheme of reconstruction stands before the country today.
A naked confessed,
stupendous failure at once.
The most remarkable and the most inexcusable failure in all of history.
Little hyperbole,
but making their case the causes,
of course,
relatively obvious,
but it was still a shock.
Certainly the republicans,
there was tremendous fatigue with a reformist in the political culture,
including the north or especially the north.
There's tremendous political fatigue with the reformist spirit of the Republican
Party.
The economic depression was absolutely central to this election.
Why the dams came back.
Okay.
The scandals and Ms Management of the grant years already setting in was a big
deal.
By 74 it's going to be an even bigger deal.
By 1876 democrats are going to portray themselves now as the reform party,
the party of civil service reform,
the party of clean government.
Okay.
Most of all,
I'd say the Republican Party by 1874 and how many times have you seen this in
American political history,
the Republican Party of 1874 payday,
high price for its recent history of support,
a black rights and the idea of racial equality just exactly as the Democratic
Party would do in the wake of Lbj,
his great society,
the 64 and 65 civil rights acts of the famous moment when Bill Moyers tells us,
or was it bill Moyers who said to Lbj,
was it Lbj to send the bill Moyers after they passed the 65 civil rights act?
Which one?
It was.
It good.
It's Lbj to bill Moyers as only LBJ could probably said something.
Well,
I'll clean it up.
Bill,
we're done lost the south for a generation because of what we just passed and
I'll be doing.
Only one only lived in 1971 of course you won't live to quite see it,
but he was absolutely right.
Yeah.
Southern redemption kept happening.
Although seven of the 11 southern x confederate states were already back under
the control of the southern Democratic Party.
Even before this now in the wake of this election,
one more will come the next year and only three will be left by the 76
presidential contest,
South Carolina,
Mississippi,
and Louisiana unredeemed as the south put put it.
This was an election also all about this emerging reunion or reconciliation of
some kind.
Let me give you a couple illustrations.
I what happened in the wake of this election
in Vicksburg,
Mississippi the following summer and it was actually a,
uh,
there's a bit about this and Nick Lemons book,
which you're reading and I'm,
I'm,
I'm sparing you any lecturing about what happened in Mississippi in 1875 because
that's what lemons book is all about.
The so called shotgun policy,
the,
the violent overthrow of reconstruction by the White Democratic Party and
Mississippi,
been in Vicksburg,
Vicksburg of all places.
Blacks held a very public 4th of July celebration in 1875.
And that was,
that took courage.
It was bold.
Their own politicians spoke,
a black Republican circuit judge gave a speech.
Okay.
The Black Secretary of state and Mississippi gave a remarkable speech is
somewhat challenging speech to the Democrats.
And justice.
He was ending his speech,
a mob of about 50 white people invaded the,
the,
the big hall.
They were having it in
a shot,
was fired as a signal and they opened up and they just started firing.
They killed two on the spot,
wounded about 10 died later.
It was the 4th of July celebration stopped by cold blooded murder.
There was an observer at this event and African American who wrote an account of
it under the pseudonym they need Iti,
which means I came,
I saw,
and it was published in the New York Herald Tribune as well as the Christian
recorder and some other places.
He laid the blame for this,
not on that white mob.
I mean they're,
they're,
they were tired of blaming the white rednecks in the south for,
for killing him.
They NAVD blamed it on national reconciliation.
He said the killings on the 4th of July in Vicksburg where,
because quote Boston and Ohio,
we're holding the coats for Georgia and Mississippi while they slay the common
victim of northern prejudice and southern hate.
That's a very clear on the ground.
I witness description of where responsibility now for this may lie not just with
the mob but with the folk who are allowing mob to do its business.
Alright,
between 80 and 74 and 1876 arguably what the country is assessing and you can
see who's winning,
what the country is assessing is the question which revolution is actually going
to win
if this is a second American revolution,
which is a construction historians have put onto this overtime with with
different meanings.
Charles Beard had a different meaning than Eric Foner and others of us have used
it,
but which revolution would prevail?
Is that the revolution of 1863 to 65 is that the revolution that Abraham Lincoln
finally named and then said would be enforced very bluntly and his second
inaugural with every drop of blood shed by the and shall be paid in bloodshed by
the sword
or
is it the other revolution?
The counterrevolution,
the white southern democratic revolution against reconstruction.
I against the changes of the civil war against the 13th 14th and 15th
Amendments,
which revolution?
The revolution of black freedom
or the redemption of white.
Okay.
Those are the stakes.
Those are very,
very high stakes.
In fact,
just let me use a picture to for the heck of it.
Um,
you know,
this may go without saying,
but not really.
Which image did Americans,
White Americans,
which image in their minds,
in their brains when they went to the polls,
what image,
when we go to the polls now,
do most white Americans want of black people?
Is it him?
Is it that genius in his perfect white shirts who could speak and write like
Gerta
and would remind you of it and would explain things in language that might make
you quiver in your seat?
Is it black genius they wanted to see
or,
yeah,
I don't know if you can see that.
Did they want to see Chloe and Sam?
It's a painting by Thomas Hovenden.
A wonderful painter is same paint or have painted that a colossal painting of
John Brown and with a rifle in one hand and the Bible in the other and hair on
fire and it's at the Metropolitan Museum in New York.
Go see you.
Anyway.
Hoven dins painting here a beautiful if sentimental.
Sure.
I'll carefully you can see this or how well you can see this with the lighting
in here.
It's Chloe and Sam.
It's too old.
Freedom.
Okay.
Sam seems to be cooling down the teapot,
maybe clothes ironing.
It got their own house.
He hunts.
They're peaceful.
That's this settled.
They're there.
They're the old,
they're the old slaves.
Does aunt Chloe and Uncle Sam and they're not going to threaten anybody.
Well,
I mean forgive this image.
Um,
and this is,
whoops.
I don't know who drew this.
It just comes from the library of Congress.
Or is this an image now that a lot of Americans,
they may not prefer it
borders.
Certainly willing to accept
about the sons and daughters of Chloe and Sam who got really assertive,
who wanted to vote,
who were holding office or walking in there,
perfect white shirts,
their suits in the halls of congress and the halls of state legislatures who
insisted on education and property ownership and
all those crazy rights of citizenship.
Why should black people be and not imagination?
All right.
The election of 1876 comes if the election of [inaudible] 74 was a referendum on
reconstruction,
the election of 1876 was a referendum,
if you like on reunion.
How indeed would this reunion actually occurred or would there really truly be a
reunion?
Now this was an election of course,
where both parties now for the first time since the civil wealth for the first
time,
really since before the civil war.
In fact,
you certainly could argue this,
it's the first time since really 1856 that two parties in an American
presidential election have faced each other as truly national and virtually
equal in power,
um,
authority membership to some degree
and so on.
It's the centennial year.
It comes in the wake of these tremendous scandals of the second grant
administration.
Whisky ring wasn't blown open until the second term credit.
Moby lay wasn't blown over until the second term,
the Belknap scandal,
not till the second term,
the Democrats.
Now in 76,
they're going to portray themselves again as they hadn't 74 but now it's a
presidential election.
Is the party reform the party of clean government.
And thank you very much.
The party of white supremacy that we'll finally put in reconstruction to death
in those three states in the south where it's still exist in some form.
The election was a test of either reunion or redemption and on whose turn the
Democrats ran for President Samuel j Tilden,
he was the governor of New York.
Governors of New York have often good candidates for president for a whole
variety of good reasons.
He was one of the richest men in the United States.
It was a very wealthy trial lawyer.
Um,
he had a reputation for reform based largely on the fact that he had gone as the
governor of New York.
He had gone after boss tweed who ran the boss system of New York City.
And as the press always put it,
he bagged him.
You got him.
He found him.
He got him on charges.
They were able to prosecute against boss tweed.
So Tilden cleaned up New York.
It said,
they said to some degree,
yeah.
No.
The Republicans in the other hand now needed
a new face,
somebody on tainted by the grant administration and somebody who had some
distance from reconstruction,
but it was still terribly important to run a veteran,
and this is going to be the case for years in American history in the south.
You couldn't get elected a governor or senator from a southern state for the
next 25 years if you weren't a confederate veteran
and it surely helps you in the north viewer union veteran.
So they went to Ohio,
that seed better presidents,
no more jokes about Ohio,
and they found Ruthford be Hayes
now haze that many things going for him.
He had indeed been a civil war vet.
He was a civil war vet.
He'd been wounded about six times in the war.
He was a serious combat survivor.
He'd also been elected governor of Ohio three times.
He was known to be a conservative,
not terribly engaged in reconstruction issues.
Oh,
he supported black rights and some sort of general way.
He will promise something for almost everyone,
depending on where he went in the Vegas possible term.
Okay.
And he will inspire a,
once again,
that's cynical sob Henry Adams for one of the best descriptions I've ever read,
a bread of Rutherford Hayes.
A little unfair that Adam's always was as a satirists.
Henry Adam said Rutherford Hayes was a quote third rate nonentity who's only
recommendation is that he is obnoxious to no one.
No.
Oh,
how many times have we done this in our politics though?
Find somebody that nobody quite knows,
don't have a lot of enemies,
got elected,
no strong views
and running
and
providing,
you don't have a year and a half bloody primary to put him through.
Now
this would be a brutal,
brutal election in its rhetoric.
Uh,
just an example to
Republicans now facing this frankly variantly openly white supremacist campaign
and the part of the Democrats,
but also facing the charges of scandal and corruption,
which are very real.
They want to misdirect peoples,
you know,
added,
uh,
their,
their attention.
They don't want people to think about those scandals.
And if they can help with,
they don't even want people to have to think about reconstruction for awhile.
So what do they do?
They waived the bloody shirt when in doubt,
in the 19th century for the Republican,
they're going to keep doing it right on up through the 1896 selection against
William William Jennings Bryan.
That's getting ahead of ourselves,
but man,
they're going to trot out every living surviving sentience civil war general by
even as late as 1896 put them on trains and barnstorm.
I'm all over the country and paint William Jennings Bryan is a succession list
because it was a populous.
At any rate,
here's one example of the kind of bloody shirt rhetoric that the Republican
party tried out against the Democrats in 1876 this came from Colonel Robert
Ingersoll cool,
famous,
agnostic,
a very popular order,
especially at Grand Army of the republic reunions and political gatherings.
He said this in September of [inaudible] 76 quote classic bloody shirt every
state did.
Seceded from the United States was a democratic state.
Every man that tried to destroy this nation was a democrat.
Every man that loves slavery better than liberty was a democrat.
The man that assassinated Abraham Lincoln was a democrat.
Every man that raised bloodhounds to pursue human beings was a democrat.
Soldiers.
Every scar you have got on your heroic bodies was given to you by a Democrat and
the union veterans and get up and cheer.
Yay.
Scars,
Democrat scar.
It worked.
It worked in a lot of places.
War is only 10 years ago,
and our hundreds of thousands of union veterans,
they are the base of the Republican Party,
a deep,
broad base,
especially across the Midwest,
which is where they're all moving.
And in the far west.
So civil war veterans are moving west
in the election.
Um,
again,
the rhetoric gut terrible.
And when the election was held,
it was a very violent election.
Uh,
we'll never know.
No one will ever know how many thousands of African American voters,
especially in the three states of Mississippi,
Louisiana and South Carolina.
Uh,
excuse me,
Mississippi,
South Carolina and Louisiana as well.
But also Florida.
We'll never know how many were intimidated and kept from the Poles.
We know it was thousands,
hundreds of thousands in all likelihood.
One Republican official in Mississippi observing the election said in his view
of the white population was essentially one vast mob.
Now,
what happened,
of course,
is it Tilden and carried all of a map here may be useful
Tilden,
I don't know how well you can see that,
but at least you can see the contours of it.
Tilled in the Democrat carried all of the solid south except now solid
democratic south except three states.
The three states remaining under republic teetering Republican regimes,
Louisiana,
South Carolina and Florida Tilden also carried for northern states,
his own North New York,
New Jersey,
Connecticut,
and Indiana
Hayes carried all the rest of the north and much of the west,
but without the three southern states counted
Mississippi,
excuse me,
Louisiana,
Florida and South Carolina.
The electoral count
and when the,
when the returns came in that night and the next day,
and it took longer in those years,
it took at least a 24 hours after an election ended and sometimes 48 hours
before they even had real official counts.
Okay.
In the electoral college.
Now.
First of all,
there's no question that at least in the votes cast,
Tilden won the popular vote,
if you like,
in the terms of numbers.
He's the Al Gore of the 876 election.
He won the popular vote of the votes cast.
Nope.
How many hundreds of thousands,
particularly black Republicans who didn't vote for fear for their lives.
We don't know the electoral college before you count to three disputed states,
the number was one 84 to one 66 Tilden to haze.
It took one 85 to be elected.
Okay.
Handwriting on the wall initially was that,
well,
even in the official Republican party offices in Washington DC,
as the returns were coming in the next day,
they were about to hold news conferences,
send out messages and say,
well,
guys,
guess we lost,
and then quickly,
quickly inside their offices they realized that there were 19 electoral votes in
the three disputed states and they said,
no news conferences,
we're going to win those three.
How raw it remains to be seen.
The disputed election of 1876 and was disputed over the three states that still
had republican regimes that had widespread fraud,
violence,
and intimidation practice in their elections.
No one will ever know as long as we live exactly who,
one where.
Although we do have some good guesses now from scholarship.
Well,
what ensued was the longest disputed election we've ever had.
The Gore Bush affair of 2000 last,
what,
35 days before the Supreme Court chose our president.
It isn't going to be a lot different here.
Oh,
the supreme court will have only a very limited role.
The official popular vote count in 1876 was 4,284,000 some odd votes for Tilden
and 4,036,000 some odd,
36,000 some odd votes for haze.
That was an official popular vote.
Well,
one of the best ways to think about this election is that frankly,
the Democrats stole it and then the Republicans stolen back.
Hate to sound so cynical,
but frankly,
folks,
that's essentially what happened under the 12th amendment to the US
Constitution.
Of course if there's a disputed election and no one gets a majority of the,
of the electoral college.
We ignored this one in 2000.
I just thought I'd point that out.
It is supposed to go to the House of Representatives and the House of
Representatives and it's a good councils shall choose.
The president says to the u s constitution and they followed the constitution in
1876 they actually did well too to a degree they did
with the country waiting with all kinds of rumors flying and the press.
I went back and studied the present in this disputed,
these disputed months.
Uh,
for this earlier book I did on memory.
And it's amazing the rumors.
I mean you've got southern papers like the Atlanta Constitution printing long
stories about local militias and upstate New York that are drilling,
calling themselves with the sons of liberty and readying themselves to march
into the south.
And you've got northern papers like Chicago Tribune printing article,
article after article about confederate mobs and malicious.
You're drilling all over this house and preparing themselves to merchant into
the north,
most of which were completely false.
But it became long tense winter months of fear,
and now of course,
when fear sets in blood memory sets in
the United States House of Representatives decided to establish an electoral
commission.
It would have 15 members.
There would be five Republicans,
five Democrats and five Supreme Court justices.
15 people.
Sounds relatively fair.
Not Quite.
Three of the Supreme Court justices were Republicans.
Two of them were Democrats.
I mean is there were eight Republicans,
seven Democrats on this electorial commission.
The job of this electoral commission was to investigate the voting returns of
the three disputed states of Louisiana,
Florida,
and South Carolina.
They would just study the return.
It's
the Democrats in Congress initiated a long filibuster and they held it.
They started a filibuster in December of 60 of 76 and they're still doing it.
I mean,
they're,
they're reading city directories and whatever other garbage,
they didn't have phone books yet.
They were just reading newspaper articles a day in and day out until the third
week,
fourth week of February of 77
nothing went on in the u s congress.
There were threats of disunion hotheaded Democrats would a announce the slogan,
Tilden or fight
President Ulysses Grant,
lame duck,
can't wait to get out of office already has his,
his ship booked for his grand tour around the world,
or he'll leave on May 17th,
uh,
for the,
the greatest tour any American ever made of planet earth.
That's another story.
Um,
but grant quietly began to rebuild and re garrison some of the forts around
Washington DC,
and Lo and behold,
the commission,
Matt and Lo and behold,
they voted.
Guess what?
Yeah,
it's a suspense.
They voted eight to seven
that the Republicans tilled.
Hayes had one in Louisiana,
Florida,
and South Carolina based on the theory of widespread farden violence.
Now,
there's a lot to that.
They never really knew what those voting counts were,
to be honest.
But the way in which the disputed election of 1876 was settled,
of course,
was ultimately not even by that electorial commission.
It was settled in the Wormley hotel on February 26th and 27th of 1877 and a 48
hour meeting between five Ohio Republicans representing Hayes and forest
southern Democrats representing Tilden.
The compromise of 1877 as it is called,
was a deal.
It was a deal based on interests not on votes.
The Democrats were willing to give up the presidency if they could get in return
what they most needed.
They wanted federal subsidies for a Western Pacific Railroad,
at least one with a southern terminus.
They wanted their harbors dredged.
They wanted federal subsidies to rebuild the infrastructure of the south.
Lo and behold,
they wanted federal money.
All these states rights.
Southern Democrats,
thank you very much.
They wanted federal money to rebuild their society.
Bring us your investments.
They'd saying for a long time,
from carpet baggers to carpet baggers,
just don't come here and try to get elected.
Here was the deal,
and by the way,
one of the chief brokers,
there were several chief brokers.
One was James Garfield of Ohio,
close personal friend and associate of Rutherford.
B Hayes,
uh,
later succeeded him as president United States and to be assassinated.
But the other great broker at the 77 compromise was Tom Scott,
the president of the ticks,
the Texas Pacific Railroad.
He'd been one of the great American railroad kings for years and he brokered
really,
especially the economic financial parts of this deal.
Here was the deal
home rule.
The Republican said would be returned to Louisiana,
South Carolina and Florida.
The Republicans agreed to let the southern Democrats take over those three
states,
abandoning their own party leaders,
abandoning a lot of black elected officials who are still running those
governments
and the Republican's promise they would help get Democrats elected governors of
those states.
Yeah,
they agreed to remove all final federal troops from the south and this has
always been a big symbolic thing as well,
which is exactly what it is.
It's a big symbolic thing.
There were very few troops left anywhere in the south and those,
those few thousand that we're still there.
We're located in forts along the coast and quietly Ulysses grant signed the bill
and the third week of February,
just before the deal at the Wormley hotel that repealed the law,
placing those troops in the south.
Yeah.
One and possibly to cabinet positions in Hayes's cabinet were promised to
southern Democrats.
They particularly promise the postmaster general ship because of its patronage
powers.
The Democrats agreed to help James Garfield become speaker of the house.
It's a deal folks.
Quid pro quo tit for tat.
The Democrats agreed to enforce.
Well,
I can almost not see this one at Democrats agreed to enforce the civil war
amendments and black civil rights.
Hmm.
And the Democrats agreed to stop their filibuster except the official count.
Wow.
Hayes to be peacefully inaugurated three days later or four days later on March
the third Rutherford B Hayes was privately inaugurated,
no outdoor inauguration on the steps of the Capitol is they are always done.
They feared a,
uh,
violence,
interruptions.
They didn't know what was going to happen.
He was privately inaugurated quietly in the east room of the White House.
Catastrophe had been averted.
Yeah.
But at what price?
See,
van Woodward once accurately called this compromise a treaty as much as a
compromise
and it's a compromise of 1850 oh remember it so often referred to as an
armistice rather than a current compromise.
This compromise of 1877 was in some ways a treaty
and oh,
by the way,
Hayes made it very clear in private communications what he'd been really saying
publicly and that is that his southern policy would be essentially his own,
his own phrase,
a let alone policy.
The south would be allowed to control its own social institutions is political
culture.
It's
wives.
Even grant himself had said that,
you know,
reconstruction was dead and maybe we made mistakes and shouldn't have even
tried.
Grant himself said to his cabinet that the 15th amendment,
he said had quote done,
the Negro,
no good.
Oh Ulysses.
And right after the inauguration and editorial in the nation magazine,
now I a fuming reformist magazine,
they wanted a clean up American corruption.
He,
God can,
it's great editor at the nation said he would joist in fact at this compromise,
this settling of this dispute.
And he announced his words,
the Negro,
he said,
will disappear now from the field of national politics.
Henceforth the nation as a nation will have nothing more to do with him.
No.
There are many meanings,
legacies,
implications of this compromise.
There are many,
uh,
long lasting implications and legacies of this compromise and this particular
end of reconstruction.
And it does seem like a sort of dead end.
A light's going out kind of moment to all that idealism or whatever we wish to
call it.
It emerged from the war.
It would leave a person like Frederick Douglass in a certain degree of despair.
He would begin to make speeches and he will the rest of his life about trying to
hold onto.
And emancipation,
just abolition is memory of the civil war and reconstruction.
He makes a speech a few years later where he's lamenting what has now been
betrayed and lost and is eroding out of their fingers.
He says,
reconstruction is only was only perhaps a rope of sand,
but
he drew upon at the end of that speech,
he drew upon one of those revolutionary moments in the Bible to try to keep a
certain degree of hope alive about what had at least been started.
He went to the Lazarus story,
the story of Jesus Raising Lazarus.
Literary literally from the dead.
Douglas said,
the assumption that the cause of the Negro is a dead issue now is delusion.
Utter delusion for the moment,
he may be buried under the dust and rubbish of endless discussion concerning
civil service reform,
tariff and free trade labor and capital,
but our Lazarus is not dead.
He only sleeps.
See you next week.